welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Captain America the First
Avenger taught us all at a salute
America's ass all those fields we felt
at old man cat feet and ducks and
adventures in games started with strong
character development clever Easter eggs
and subtle foreshadowing that means so
much more than how than ever after this
infinity saga rewatch has turned up new
details an Iron Man Hulk Iron Man 2 and
Thor let us now turn to the og team
America
yeah language sorry okay the film opens
with the discovery of Steve Rogers
frozen an ice originally caps frozen
caveman body was gonna be revealed and
an Incredible Hulk deleted scene it said
they do it here in the movie with his
name in the title Captain America was
one of the Golden Age World War 2 era
heroes from timely comics which later
became Marvel Comics and they brought
him back in the 60s thought amount for
mice to join The Avengers a generation
later this is the cap explored in the
MCU a man out of his time haunted by a
fear of missing out on the life he was
meant to live and we'll see how this
fear will thrust cap and the whole MCU
forward fomo thrust onto tonsberg norway
past setting of the battle between odin
in the process and future home of new
Asgard and endgame Odin gave the
Norwegians his crown jewel the tesseract
a history we might have seen in that
mythology bouken Thor now in 1942 Johann
Schmidt arrives to find it
Schmidt leads Hydra then the Nazis
science division before going rogue
he drives a sick v16 roadster and like
Tony Stark's Ford Roadster the ride
reflects the identity so it's time for a
wheelbarrow designed by Daniel Simon the
bodywork is based on the mercedes-benz
540 k with mercedes g4 four-wheel drive
in vintage Duesenberg and Bentley design
language with V a dragster engine from
Ford in place in the Mercedes hood
ornament is the Hydra logo
see I just shifted gear back in a nerd
there the Hydra based on the Greek
mythological head respawn and monster
this logo also appears on Schmidt's pin
with blood dripping on the skull
foreshadowing his Red Skull identity
also if you look real closely the seam
line of Schmidt's flesh mask is visible
behind his ear Smith's mythological
obsession has led him to this church
kept by Balder Filch and he recognizes
the engraving as the major soul world's
tree mentioned in Thor and the secret
box is carved with a serpent in the
tree's roots this snake is named Norman
gander the Midgar
serpent a Norse mythology beasts and
mythological kin of Luke II Red Skull is
one of caps oldest bows in the comics
and he's often after the Cosmic Cube
which many of us believe the tesseract
was based on but his shattering of this
decoy cube reflects how the real
tesseract is in the Cosmic Cube we
thought it was but secretly an infinity
stone this movie was directed by Joe
Johnston who won an Oscar for his
effects work and Raiders of the Lost Ark
and this line was a nod to the Nazi date
for the Ark in Egypt this first cap
movie shares several similarities with
Raiders Lost Ark of world war two ERA
throwback adventure exploring Hitler's
known fixation with occult relics enemy
soldiers getting chopped up by propeller
blades and a finale showing the arrogant
Prometheus sucked into the cosmos by the
wrath of God but next we meet our hero
Steve Rogers skinny Steve here was an
effect created by Lola the effects
company that made Curious Case of
Benjamin Button they recorded Chris
Evans four times in these scenes first a
normal shoot with Chris Evans lowered to
adjust the eyelines
second Evans on a green screen so he
could be reduced to digitally third the
scene on set without Evans
so that digitally shrunken Steve could
be reinserted and fourth with a body
double stage actor leander Dini
to mimic evidence movements for these
shots they would graft Evans face onto
the double team pisses off an America
hatin heckler into an alley fight for
shadowing his real shield with a trash
one you just don't know when to give up
do you great line he could repeat all
day in future fights I can do this all
day
Bucky Barnes bails him out okay you
clean up why we going
clever foreshadowing by Marvel here
hinting at the future of both these men
World War two soldiers resurrected in
the present day and they attend the
stark Expo Internet by the later spark
Expo an Iron Man to Howard Stark shows
off his hovering car stock for vidiq
reversion technology
Howard's reversion tech is likely the
precursor to Tony's repulsor tech though
like Tony's mark 1 and mark 2 armors
Howard's test models hilariously crashed
and agents of shield Agent Coulson
actually shows up a successful remodel
of Howard's tech another exhibit at this
Expo shows a red suit labeled with dr.
Phineas Horton this is a nod to the
original Human Torch in the early timely
comics who was part of the invaders with
cap and named work Marvel Comics later
recycled the name and abilities to
create the character of Johnny Storm of
the Fantastic Four who was played by
Chris Evans in the Fox films and at the
time of this movie not owned by Marvel
Studios but now is once again so hurry
up and fully mon foggy
Steve mopes over his - short reflection
a shot echoed and into the spider-verse
again afraid he will miss out on the
fight Bucky heads off don't do anything
stupid until I get back how can I take
another stupid with you a line that
comes back in there goodbye an end game
don't do anything stupid till I get back
how can i you're taking all the stupid
with you dr. Abraham earth sky and
interviews Steve goofer on this
delicious mmm
is it new - Oh almost Brooklyn
there actually is a statue of Captain
America in Brooklyn first guy and says
he's from Queens and Steve being from
Brooklyn is a memory that brings a smile
to his face in civil war with spider-man
were you from pleased Brooklyn meanwhile
Schmidt meets with dr. Arne Missoula
Birth shown with his face projected on a
screen a nod to his alternate robot form
in the comics and how he will return as
a ghost in the machine and Winter
Soldier and later the movie there's a
quick shot of Zola's diagrams of a robot
body among his paperwork a nod to Zola's
comic form Schmidt looks at ancient art
photos that have been doctored to add
the tesseract one of these shows the
carved wooden doorway of a church in
house stead Norway depicting the hero
staggered helping a Smith forge a sword
which is a good ways to slay a dragon
later the movies similar depictions of
Sigurd appear behind Schmidt and
Erskine's backstory and in the sea
when Schmidt has his portrait painted he
listens to upper music by Richard Wagner
which recounts this exact Norse Lord we
visit the camp Lehi a setting that
returns with Winter Soldier and in-game
here Steve meets Peggy Carter and the
jerk soldier she punches is Gilmore
Hodge another soldier from the comics
Colonel Phillips quotes General George
Patton wars are fought with weapons but
they are won by man this weapons versus
warrior conflict will be the core
dynamic between Steve and Tony Stark is
heroism the tools you give a man to
fight with or his heroism inside him
waiting to be unbuttoned Steve struggles
through basic training falling behind
and again we see his fear of missing out
and his dive on the grenade is his
response to that fear and Steve's mind
this is his one chance to save lives and
help the war effort first guy tells
Steve about his past with Schmitt who
took a version of the Super Soldier
Serum that altered his look an updated
version of red skulls origin from the
1990s Captain America movie and we
learned in the Incredible Hulk that
general Ross is Super Soldier Serum
research was an attempt to recreate or
skeins formula versed kinds a leus and
fighter Ray's shows up on the tank and
Hulk steve's eyes here shoot open just
like banners do and later we see Steve
giving blood samples for future testing
here Erskine tell Steve that the serum
reflects the identity inside the man so
if you think about it Red Skull and
abomination are kind of like evil freak
brothers
Peggy escorts Steve to the lab women
aren't exactly lining up to dance with
the guy they might step on a line
setting up their goodbyes later
what neck look folks finding these
details can be quite a challenge but a
much less fun challenge is finding
coupon codes that actually work when
you're shopping online well with honey
it doesn't have to be this hard
thanks to honey for sponsoring this
video honey is the free online shopping
tool that automatically finds promo
codes and applies them to your cart
let's say you're shopping online at
Target or Game Stop Domino's wherever
when you check out there's this little
box that drops down and all you have to
do is click apply coupons wait a few
seconds for it to scan promo codes from
across the internet and watch the prices
drop recently I was shopping for an
outdoor rug for my little patio space
and I found one on target calm and honey
save me over 18 bucks I was gonna buy
the rug anyways but now I have my rug
and an extra 18 dollars new rock stars
fans that have already downloaded honey
in the past using our promo code have
already saved themselves over
two hundred and forty three thousand
dollars that's enough to buy a couple
boxers with scraps not having honey is
literally passing up free money it's
free finds coupons with one click and
it's now part of the venmo and PayPal
families so you know it's legit get
honey for free at joint honeycomb slash
new rock stars that's join honey calm
slash new rockstars Earth's kind
explains his Super Soldier Serum change
the exact makeup of the serum that
Erskine used on cap remains a bit of a
mystery though some believe that if
shield had access to wakandan vibranium
part of it might have been a distilled
wakandan heart-shaped herb which might
be why later capita t'challa's physical
strength has seemed too evenly matched
and money shot cap beefed up
this taller description comes back later
in a cameo from Stanley I thought he'd
be taller by the way that guy next to
him is a cameo by red brown who played
Captain America in the 70s movies first
kinda is killed by a Hydra spy in the
State Department setting up the long
tradition of US government officials
loyal to Hydra
senators turn agent Sitwell Secretary
Pierce Steve shield himself with a taxi
door with a star stage two of his
practical shield evolution from trash to
repurposed parts here to a stage prop to
a prototype to the real thing kind of
reflecting Tony Stark's armour evolution
from a box of scraps to a silver
prototype to the real thing the Hydra
submarine like many of hydras futurist
texts in this movie was based on real
Nazi designs this Pfizer Dorsch was
based on the German martyr and high red
skulls rocket was based on the [ __ ] wolf
tribe of moogle in the Valkyrie with its
solo bombers were based on the Whorton
h18 bomber and the fighter plane called
the tribe of flugel agar Mya propensity
should probably just pissed off a lot of
you Germans Schmidt test his weaponry on
Nazis you will be brought before the
field
notice the charged up sound effect
matches the charge above Iron Man's
repulsors it is bullied that Howard
Starks arc reactor which Tony based his
armors arc reactor on was powered with
energy derived from the space stone in
the tesseract actually later we'll see
Howard tinkering with a tiny piece of
tesseract fuel which matches the framing
of his son in endgame tinkering with the
Infinity stones so Steve joins a war
effort with the PR campaign he wears his
classic Captain America getup with his
winged headgear and classic shield this
whole section really cleverly satirizes
the Golden Age cap whose original
purpose was legitimately war propaganda
and selling war bonds
Steve punches Hitler restaging the
original Captain America number one
cover which we see kids reading in this
movie
what's pointed out that cap creator Joe
Simon said they got some hate mail from
American Nazi sympathizers for that
cover creating Captain America was their
political response to the overwhelming
anti interventionalist movement in the
u.s. prior to Pearl Harbor so those of
you who say that comics should stay on
the line politics is their lane one of
the dames who gets his autograph is
played by Laura haddock who also plays
Meredith quill
star-lords mother in the guardians of
the galaxy movies and the closing number
for shadows caps shield design
concentric red and white circles with
blue in a star in the center even though
this kind of stage time Howard and Tony
Stark would revel in clearly Steve
doesn't enjoy it he knows he's missing
out on the real fight a man out of his
time so he feels miserable facing real
frontline soldiers drawing himself as a
circus monkey this is actually a nod to
Steve's work as an artist in the comics
his sketching comes back in a deleted
scene for the Avengers and the artists
portfolio he keeps his shield in an end
game suggesting that part of old Steve's
new life was to sketch more and this
particular monkey drawing shows up
framed on Steve's desk in Civil War so
tired of missing out Steve sets off to
rescue Bucky and the rest of the 107th
these POWs include the Howling Commandos
Dum Dum Dugan he lets out his signature
wahoo later in the tank
Gabe Jones who might be related to
Antoine Triplett and agents of shield he
said that his grandfather was a howling
commando the lineup also includes James
falls worth the first Union Jack in the
Marvel Comics shock Danny a and Jim
Marita with Kenneth Choi also playing
his grandson principal Morita and
spider-man homecoming there's actually
an old photo of Grandpa Jim in his
office Kevin Feige originally also
wanted cameos by James Logan Howlett's
Wolverine who did join the Howling
Commandos in the animated series he also
wanted cameo from a young Erik Lehnsherr
Magneto's would show up in an internment
camp but again there were rights issues
at the time but not anymore so Sean
Feige when Steve finds Bucky he's
recovering from some procedure this
could explain how Bucky was able to
survive the fall from the Train like
maybe some early prelim dosages of their
Super Soldier serum that Hydra will
later continue to make him a Winter
Soldier schmidt reveals himself as Red
Skull and escapes and Steve returns a
hero but Peggy again reinforces his man
out of time complex you're late and
despite progress with Peggy cap remains
of victim bad timing with Peggy catching
him with private Lorraine played by
Natalie Dormer Margaery Tyrell from Game
of Thrones Howard gives Steve a new
shield made from vibranium a shield that
Peggy does not know whether it's
bulletproof when she tries to murder him
did Howard get this vibranium comics
have suggested as researchers discovered
it in the deepest Africa though ulysses
klaw brags that he's the only person to
steal vibranium formal kata and make it
out alive other comics have suggested
that Roxxon discovered vibranium
deposits on a small island in the South
Atlantic scattered there from the impact
of the vibranium meteorite collision so
Howard's team could have found fragments
of vibranium in other nearby African
countries as Steve leads missions we see
his compass with Peggy's picture which
of course returns an endgame as Steve
course corrects back to his North Star
cap Bucky and the commandos target a
Hydra train remember when I made you
ride the cyclone at Coney
Peter Parker actually purchased on this
Coney Island rollercoaster at the end of
spider-man homecoming and we get a brief
glimpse of Bucky with the shield but the
gods punished him by not get him into a
gorge which is similar to Bucky's up
rank death in the comics while other
phase 1 movies show future Avengers
getting hammered or hungover before the
final act caps enhanced metabolism makes
it hard for him to get drunk we actually
dug into the math on this on how many
shots did have to take the get drunk and
episode a big question fun one check it
out cap leads the charge in hydras out
space and chases down Valkyrie and red
skulls coupe Colonel Phillips pushes the
red button with the letter K on it with
the German around it translating to
danger do not push which gives the car a
boost this is a nod to Tommy Lee Jones
character Agent K whose car has a
similar red button cap boards Valkyrie
and confronts Red Skull this line came
up in our recent Red Skull episode of
rogue theory check it out indeed cat's
future uniform in Infinity Ward does
lose its American iconography Red Skull
meets his Ark of the Covenant style
fates with the space stone will shoot
him into the cosmos later revealed an
infinity war to be guarding the soul
stone a Vermeer cap takes the Valkyrie
into the water with a heartfelt goodbye
to Peggy and as she sobs notice the
music
[Music]
this same music comes back an endgame
first when cap sees Peggy 1970
[Music]
and then at the end after his life with
her is complete
this is not just the music of their time
together it's the theme of Steve missing
Peggy the music of longing for the life
that you're meant to live pretty
heartbreaking for end game to bring it
back after Peggy presumably passed away
poor guys agelessness always makes them
a man out of his time
Peggy finds the photo of skinny Steve
that she keeps on her desk and in this
pile you can see his canonical birthday
of July 4th Howard Stark recovers the
tesseract from the ocean floor setting
up its future with project Pegasus that
Loki will exploit in the next film The
Avengers and in the epilogue Steve wakes
up in the present day repeating his
frantic run through the streets in New
York but whereas before he woke up
taller now he wakes up with his
surroundings taller and he leaves Nick
Fury with the perfect final line for the
man out of its time forever missing out
and not until the clothes and images of
Avengers end game well the man out of
his time finally come home to the life
he wanted and take Peggy up on that
dance until then caps gonna be busy
giving us some cool [ __ ] to break down
join our watch long for the Avengers on
discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash new rockstars comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
on Instagram and Twitter a da boss
Harlan new rock stars and subscribe for
more infinity so I can break down so
that YouTube like cap will get every
reference understood that rivers
[Music]
you
[Music]